Which meant it turns out was a very
central part of the constitution of the
United States.
Meaning it's obscure.
People don't know about it,
but it probably was necessary for the
constitution actually to be ratified by
the American people.
You can see the impeachment clause,
and I'm going to explain its content in
a moment,
but you can see it as,
um,
part of the American revolution itself
in the sense that the revolt against a
king who was a leader who had authority
over we the people was,
um,
incomplete.
If we didn't have a mechanism by which
we could get rid of our leaders,
including the president,
which was a way of ensuring that we
didn't have anything like a monarchy.
Now,
the way impeachment worked is that in
the early American colonies before
America was America,
we started impeaching,
uh,
people who were following orders from
the king.
And what that meant was that,
uh,
an abusive authority would be called out
by some legislative assembly.
And in the initial phase,
what would happen would be there just be
a vote that the person had abused
authority.
And then if the thing,
uh,
fell to completion and this goes back to
England,
there'd be a trial.
And in the trial the person would be
convicted of the offense for which
impeachment was had and if convicted,
the person would be removed from office.
So to bring this back to the American
structure as a developed after the
revolution and after the constitution
came into place,
and this was thought through with such
care in Philadelphia when the
constitution was debated,
the idea was that if there is a high
crime and misdemeanor and we can talk a
bit about what that means,
or if there's trees in or bribery,
then the house of Representatives by
majority vote can impeach the president,
the vice president,
Supreme Court justices,
um,
members of the cabinet.
And what that means is there's a kind of
official,
um,
judgment that the person has done
something very,
very bad.
And after that,
the proceeding moves to the Senate,
which is acting like a court and which
decides whether to convict,
which means to remove the person from
office.
The house makes the impeachment vote by
a majority vote.
That doesn't mean anyone has to leave
office.
It then goes to the Senate,
which if it votes by a two thirds
majority,
uh,
to convict on the ground on which the
blood say president was impeached,
then the person is,
uh,
as they say about baseballs that are hit
very hard,
the president has gone.
Yes.
So,
uh,
because the word high crimes and
misdemeanors seems to mean kind of
felonies,
high crimes and misdemeanors.
The normal current reader would think,
oh,
is there a crime?
If you go back to the 18th century,
it's actually a lot more inspiring like
that then that and um,
uh,
kind of fitting with a system that's
committed to us self government.
So if there's a crime,
let's call it a jaywalking or
shoplifting or not paying your income
taxes,
that's not a high crime or misdemeanor
in the constitutional sense.
What is meant by high crime and
misdemeanor is an abuse of official
authority and shoplifting or income tax
evasion.
That's a crime.
It's not an abuse of official authority.
If the president of the United States,
let's suppose a decides,
I'm going to pardon every police officer
who shot an African American,
that's not itself likely to be a crime.
The president has the pardon power,
but that is definitely an impeachable
offense.
In fact,
James Madison spoke of abuse of the
pardon power as an impeachable offense.
If the president of the United States
decides I'm going to go on vacation in
Paris for the next six months cause it's
really beautiful.
That's certainly not a crime but it's an
impeachable offense.
That's an egregious neglect of uh,
the authority of the office.
So abusive,
the authority of the office,
if it's egregious,
pardon power example would be one.
Um,
if the president of starts invading
civil liberties in a terrible way by a
locking people up for insufficient
reason,
by going crazy in terms of security
measures at airports and borders.
And by going crazy,
I'm using that as kind of a legal term
of art really exceeding the bounds of
the reasonable.
That is not a crime,
but that is an abuse of authority.
And there were right back in,
uh,
the impeachment clause,
which is I think first and foremost way
of preserving our are our rights and
liberties and a way of calling out an
authority who has invaded them.
Think now about,
uh,
what the American revolution was fought
for.
And so I've spent a lot of the last
months in the 18th century and uh,
uh,
the people back then,
we're on the impeachment issues and
presidential authority issues.
They were off the charts good in the
debate in Virginia on whether we should
ratify the constitution.
One really,
um,
learned person said,
we cannot ratify this constitution and
the reason is the pardon power and it
was urged by the skeptic.
The president could participate in
something really sinister with one of
his advisors.
Then his advisor is in legal trouble and
then the president can pardon the person
for engaging in illegal or corrupt
activity that the president initiated.
How can we allow a constitution that has
that in it?
That's a fair question.
And it was stated with great precision
as an objection to the constitution as I
recall by someone who had actually
signed the declaration of independence.
And I know that person was at the
constitutional convention and refuse to
embrace it.
James Madison,
uh,
very quietly responded and he said,
I think the gentleman has overlooked
something isn't about a sweet way of,
uh,
responding to someone when the stakes
are super high.
Whether we're going to have a
constitution is the gentleman is
overlooked something.
And then Madison explained if the
president uses the pardon power to
shelter someone who's done something
terrible,
uh,
there's something available on the
constitution.
Impeachment and Madison actually did his
interlocutor one better.
The interlocutor was saying,
if the president advises something
terrible and participates and then,
uh,
pardons the person.
Isn't that awful?
Madison said,
yes,
that's awful.
And that's impeachable Madison's words
seem to go beyond that to say,
if you pardon someone who's,
who's done something terrible or one of
your own people,
that's itself a legitimate grounds for
impeachment,
which suggested that abusive the pardon
power in the words of James Madison,
that's an impeachable offense.
And with respect to the meaning of the
Constitution,
uh,
it is hazardous to argue with James
Madison.
The beauty of the impeachment mechanism
is its connection with the principle
that we have a republican,
not a monarchy,
which means it puts we the people in
charge.
That means that invocation of the
impeachment mechanism,
whether it's a democratic president,
a Republican president,
really depends on we the people.
So if you think of examples,
uh,
there was some interest in under
President Bush and President Obama,
some interest in impeaching them.
But I think,
you know,
thank goodness,
uh,
we,
the people,
even if we didn't like either of those
presidents,
didn't think there was an impeachable
offense under President Nixon.
By contrast and I believe,
um,
very unfortunately under president
Clinton because he didn't commit an
impeachable offense,
but under both of them,
there was a public demand for getting
rid of him on the ground that,
uh,
President Nixon had,
abused his presidential authority to,
uh,
cover up crimes and also had himself use
presidential authority to invade civil
rights and civil liberties,
uh,
that got people,
whatever their political affiliation
sufficiently charged up that they
either,
uh,
we're willing to go along with those
members of the House of Representatives
who wanted to impeach Nixon or they
fueled that.
In the Clinton case.
Uh,
there was a thought,
and again,
perjury and obstruction of justice,
which were the charges against President
Clinton.
There's nothing good about them.
They're very bad,
but they weren't,
in his case,
impeachable offenses under the
constitution.
Nonetheless,
people were charged up.
A lot of people were charged up.
So whether the president is a Democrat
or Republican,
whether it's president trump or in the
future,
you know,
some,
uh,
left or center president,
if people think that there's something
that really is beyond the Pale,
and that's not the constitutional tasks,
but it's the kind of Colloquia who have
getting at the constitutional task
beyond the Pale of a legitimate uses of,
of authority,
then we,
the people,
um,
uh,
we're the boss.
So the question,
who's the boss?
Uh,
the first three words of the
constitution say it,
we,
the people and the impeachment clause
kind of makes that real.